we're told that six identical potato
core cubes were isolated from a potato
the initial weight of each cube was
recorded each cube was then placed in
one of six open beakers each containing
a different sucrose solution
the cubes remained in the beakers for 24
hours at a constant temperature of 23
degrees celsius
after 24 hours the cubes were removed
from the beakers blotted and re-weighed
the percent change in mass due to a net
gain or loss of water was calculated for
each cube and the results are shown in
the graph to the right so this graph
right over here
a straight line is drawn on the graph to
help estimate results from other sucrose
concentrations not tested
using the straight line on the graph
calculate the water potential in bars of
the potato core cubes at 23 degrees
celsius give your answer to one decimal
place so pause this video and see if you
can work that out
all right so first let's make sure we're
understanding what's going on here so
there was a potato
we took six cubes from that potato
and we stuck those six cubes into six
different sucrose molarity solutions
and so this data point right over here
this was a situation where we took one
of the cubes so this was a sucrose
solution this was a solution actually
that contained no sucrose and so when we
put the cube in that solution
we saw a net gain of mass it looks like
it's about 22 percent gain in mass and
so that would have happened because
water would have flowed into
into the cube now the other extreme
right over here this is a solution that
has a lot of sucrose in it a very high
sucrose concentration and when we put a
cube in there we see that the mass of
that cube went down by 25 percent and
that would have been because of a net
outflow of water from that cube
so how do we figure out the water
potential of the core cubes at 23
degrees celsius
well we could think about a situation
where there's some sucrose concentration
where if the cube and the sucrose
solution have the same water potential
then you're not going to have any net
inflow or outflow
and so where do we see that on the graph
well what we'd want to do we have that
line where they're trying to fit the
data points and so where would we expect
to see zero percent change in mass so we
would go right over here to zero percent
change in mass
we would go to the line right over there
and then we see that this line would
would say that there's a zero percent
change in mass see if this is 0.4 right
over here
this is
0.5 right over here so this is about a
0.44
molar sucrose solution 0.44
molar solution so if we can figure out
the water potential of this
0.44 molar sucrose solution well that's
also going to be the water potential of
the potato cubes well how do we do that
well we've seen the equations before
where we introduced ourselves to the
idea of water potential that water
potential using the greek letter psi
is going to be equal to the solute
potential plus the pressure potential
now we're dealing with all open
containers we don't have anything that's
some piston or something that's pressing
down on these containers and so because
of that the pressure
potential is going to be equal to zero
and so we just have to figure out the
solute potential so the solute potential
we have introduced ourselves to this
formula in previous videos
it's negative i
times c times r
times t
this i right over here this is our
ionization constant this is since we're
dealing with sucrose solution it says
okay if i took sucrose and put it into
water every one of those sucrose
molecules does it stay one molecule or
does it disassociate well sucrose just
disassociates doesn't dissociate at all
it just stays one molecule so this would
be one if we're dealing with say sodium
chloride each sodium chloride molecule
would disassociate into a sodium ion and
a chloride ion and so then this would be
2 but this was 1 for sucrose
c
is the molarity of our solution and so
we estimated that to be
0.44
so let me write this down
our
solute water potential
is going to be equal to negative 1
times 0.4
0.44 i should say and that's going to be
moles
i'll write down all the units
moles per liter
times it's sometimes called the pressure
context the pressure constant in this
context but this is also the universal
gas constant and if you were doing
something like the ap exam they would
give you what this is so this is 0.0831
liters
times bars
all of that over
mole kelvin if you're used to seeing
other values of this it's probably
because they're dealing with other units
right over here but this is the
universal gas constant and then we have
to multiply that times the temperature
that we're dealing with in kelvin
now it's 20 23 degrees celsius to
convert to kelvin we just add to 273
so 273 plus 23 is going to be
kelvin
and so this is going to be equal to we
have a negative here and we could look
at the units we have the liter canceling
out liters moles canceling out with
moles kelvin canceling out with kelvin
so we're going to get something in bars
which makes sense that is the unit for
our water potential
and then
we get the calculator out
so we have
.44
times .0831
times 296. 296
is equal to and they want us to round
our answer to one decimal place so
approximately 10.8 and we already had
that negative out front so negative
10.8 bars and we're done